I'm like so Cantonese tell her your
brother I heard dressed up as your
characters okay we member comes to set
you put them in the hand mates costume
it's like one of the great gifts of the
show like a shoes and his beard oh my
gosh he's taking it so seriously I think
he looks lovely I think he looks lucky
the best circulate ever speaking of this
role though you play some pretty intense
roles I mean are you like attracted to
those like what do you do to unwind from
all that seriousness I you know I love
hallmark movies oh you go opposite I do
I go right home our Christmas movies and
my sisters I mean this is like we love
these they're happy they feel good yeah
and they always end happy and we
discover the magic of Christmas and it's
no one oh my gosh they got together the
home our gap on my phone oh my god
that's awesome my sister I bet hi there
okay it's very and I actually talked
recently about my love for Hallmark
Christmas movies especially and like the
next day hallmark reached out and was
like yeah and was like we would love to
do something with you and I and I wanted
to make it really clear that I wasn't
kidding like I wasn't making fun of them
this wasn't ironic I was like I want to
do a Hallmark Christmas I would it was a
seminar
it's a huge thing and mice females I
know are like but especially costs them
and I want to make like a real hallmark
Christmas movie I want to do all of the
things so we're actually looking into it
we might do something I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this